this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual
amazing relationships this is a show
about your life ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today as we answer
your questions the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five matt starts off this hour in
huntsville hey matt welcome to the
ramsey show
yeah dave thanks for having me on
first-time caller long-term fan well
thank you brother how can we help today
well um i went to some of my first
financial peace classes about 10 years
ago the my wife and i worked really hard
at becoming debt-free which we did good
for you about a year a year and a half
ago good for you and
now i'm trying to figure out you know
next chapter of my life how do i how do
i plan for
you know potential early retirement and
or you know just doing something
different
and one of my concerns is long-term care
insurance
and i'm sort of a
i mean i hate to say this but i'm sort
of an anti-insurance guy just because of
the cost ah that would be all of us
okay good we believe in never buying
insurance unless it's absolutely
necessary
exactly exactly and so anyway so it's
one of those last pieces that i'm trying
to figure out do i really need it or not
how old are you from financial
standpoint
how old are you
i'm 55. okay and what's your net worth
now
4.2 million you don't need it
great
that's simple all right let me give you
that now let me tell you why i said that
and see if you agree with me okay sure
the average nursing home stay is 2.4
years
yeah
uh the average and the average is about
100 000 a year so let's call it quarter
million dollars okay
so your risk is
zero to 500 thousand
right
yep if i did those numbers right you can
handle that risk if you burn through
five hundred thousand mama's left with
three and a half she's gonna party when
you're gone
yep
yeah for multiple reasons
she's got plenty left to throw a party a
big wake is because we're all going to
be sad but yeah but
yeah i'm just i'm talking to you like my
wife talks to me so there you go but uh
no i get it i get it
yeah i mean you you got and you got five
years so by the way if you do nothing
with that net worth except keep it
invested at around a 10 rate of return
your four and a half in seven years will
be nine
yeah and you'll be 62
the chances of someone going into a
nursing home and spending a dollar with
a nursing home prior to age 60 is very
close to zero
statistically
so so let me ask you this would you
recommend you know kind of
putting that into some sort of a safe
fund for the future or
just keep on investing and just you got
nine and a half million you can come up
with a half million yeah okay got it yep
you're gonna be fine i mean you just got
a big chunk of mutual funds in your 401k
she needs to write some checks the
nursing home because you get early
dementia or whatever on set then boom
she writes checks and she burns through
a half million she's more than good
because here's the thing 75 of the
ladies outlive their husbands yeah
and so the normal scenario with someone
with a three or five hundred thousand
dollar net worth
is papa goes in the nursing home burns
burns through the nest egg cracks and
scrambles the nest egg
and gets taken care of and dies and
leaves mama broke
so this is why if you've got three to
five hundred thousand in net net worth
you definitely buy long-term care
insurance the day you turn 60. it's your
birthday present to your wife
yeah but in your case you're
self-insured i'm self-insured i'm 61 i
didn't buy it okay i got plenty of money
sharon's got plenty of money she's got
too much money if i die it's not good so
i'm having to sleep with one eye open
but yeah so that's yeah you're good matt
you're good so yeah and so long-term
care insurance is a little bit like um
the old willie nelson joke about taxes
right
you you either want to have um
be broke and the government provides you
with nursing home care through medicaid
welfare
and you're 100 broke or you need to be
so wealthy that you can you know 10
million dollars and you can afford a
half million yeah it's the it's the folk
in the middle they can get burned up
with it and the old joke with the
wayland jennings told uh willie nelson
was that he said you know the irs is
suing me for a million dollars and
jennings said that's really good because
if it was fifteen thousand dollars you'd
have a problem since it's a million
dollars they got a problem
it's that kind of thing so you want to
be on one end of the other of it and
that you know that that's a
but it's a really good kind of insurance
to have if you're in that slot where
you've got less than a million dollar
net worth
greater than poverty level net worth
because you're going to go through some
serious money and you're going to feel
people have this emotional reaction as
if the nursing home somehow
you know uh uh robbed them you know
pointed a gun at them and i don't want
the nursing home to get all my money you
know i was like well you don't want the
restaurant to get all your money but you
keep going over there and eating you
know right so
they provide a service you pay for it
there's a third option stacy and i've
discussed this i don't know how serious
she is
but you know i get to that point instead
of paying the nursing home i just told
her to take me out to the alaskan bush
and just let me wander off and let the
kodiaks take care of me you know
can
it's a joke
with the kodiaks in you this is not a
picture i can deal with it's just you
know
coaching he'd be out there coaching him
on a new career i would be i'd be well
i'd be talking to a tree you know kodiak
let him just go out there and wander
wander off you're just you're horrible i
know paige is in salt lake city hey
paige what's up
hey thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
um my question's kind of a two-parter
one um i am a college student and i was
just wondering what's the best way to
find scholarships online
without being scammed
and what site what do you think about
the sites that find the scholarship for
you but require subscription fee
to do so
yeah we've investigated most of them
actually consider buying two of them
on the subscription and the problem we
found is is there's kind of two classes
of this scholarship stuff that shows up
in these databases
uh one class of scholarship is kind of
hard to find because they don't spend a
lot of money advertising the fact that
they give out a scholarship and it's a
legitimate scholarship it's the
the kiwanis club
they're in your county and they put out
2 500
but they really don't have like a big
site and they don't spend a lot of time
putting it on one of the subscription
sites and paying them for it to be on
there so they can give away money
uh that's who you're really after then
there's another kind of scholarship that
we don't talk about a lot here but we're
finding it as we do research in the
space because i'm dying to build some
kind of product to help you guys and i
just haven't been able to figure out a
way to do it yet our product team has
been working on it for about two years
but um and that's why we've investigated
but the other con that's there's this
litter this clutter
in the space and it's they're
scholarships but they're
they're not really scholarships they're
really putting the scholarship out there
to collect your data
and to get you to sell you something
and so it's kind of a it's kind of a
fishing expedition on their part and
those are the ones you're running into
that are pissing you off i can tell
um you talk about scammed i mean you
know you know so you don't want to pay
to do that for sure so the the truth of
the matter is is that you've got some
work to do
to dig out the hard-to-find ones
and to comb through some of the
subscriptions if you get one scholarship
and you paid for a subscription 200 a
year and you got a thousand dollar
scholarship you came out okay but you
are gonna have some crap in there that
you gotta wade through to get to it um
and you know just keep following
christina ellis our ramsey personality
she's the absolute expert on this stuff
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
imagine the energy of a jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to change their
lives
picture all your favorite speakers on
stage to help you do that whether it's
marriage or career or mental wellness or
becoming a millionaire or leadership or
getting out of debt it's not just
another pep talk this is thousands of
people just like you it's called smart
conference
craig and amy groschel from life church
will be speaking on marriage all the
ramsey personalities will be speaking on
their chosen
topics it is a day-long smart conference
it's back there's going to be about 8
000 people in the room we've already
sold almost half of those tickets it's
october the 22nd a saturday in dallas
tickets are a whole 39 dollars and when
you spend that money and you come spend
the day with us you will be smarter it's
the smart conference
ramsay solutions dot com slash events
and uh you can always join us there
we've also got four building wealth
events in the fall in orlando phoenix
sacramento minneapolis and san antonio
make sure you get out to one of these
events we would love to meet you sign
your book take a pic with you hang out
do all that smiley stuff because we love
people and we think people should be
around people people need people
yeah right now now i'm turning into the
lonely i'm singing off-key yeah that's
awful and i'm here for it yeah i'm right
here for it it's what it's what's called
co-hosting i love it
you get to endure this crap all right
nick is with us in indianapolis hey nick
how are you
i'm great dave it's honored to speak
with you and ken as well i've been
listening to you for years and years
sure what's up
okay um
your phone is all scratchy and bad and
ugly can you make it pretty
hello um
you hear me better now uh a little bit
let's try it
okay um
i've went through a lot of
in the past few years um
i have
uh went through divorce and lost both my
parents all within
uh five years or so um i'm
i have a
criminal record i have a dui on my
record and um
other possession charges i was a heroin
addict for five years after my parents
died
and uh
i've been two years sober now good for
you yeah i've i've i'm having a hard
time budgeting because
i don't make enough money i make half of
what i used to and
it just feels like i'm barely surviving
on what i make what are you doing right
now what are you doing for work
i'm a mechanic
i i went to trade school right out of
right out of high school and uh
so i'm an auto mechanic or what
yeah auto mechanic at a dealership i i
used to be you know for uh
and then i went to school you got your
you got your driver's license back after
the
dui yeah okay so you're driving you just
have a record and you've been drive for
three you've been dry off the heroine
for three years
yeah and the
the the insurance companies at the
dealership they won't they won't accept
any duis within like 10 years so
i have to work at a private you know
like a little
small lot and they don't pay as well and
other things what are you making right
now per hour as a mechanic
20 an hour okay
what could you make
let's say yeah what could you make if
you didn't have any of these record
issues what would the rate be that you
would expect to make
40.
okay so the insurance the insurance at
the dealership is to ensure what
your health insurance
no the
so
like the uh
the
insurance the the dealership has to
ensure me to drive all the customers
cars
you know just the liability that they
have for me to drive i got you okay you
know how long ago was the dui
um three years ago okay how long before
it drops off on this issue
they said that they can go back 10 years
i think it might be seven but they said
10. okay all right so we know we're
dealing basically i'm trying to
yeah i'm trying to make it by until then
and then i'll have you know i'll be fine
after that no i don't want you to make a
battle then i want you to go beat the
system we got to figure this out yeah so
the gap here is
you're making 20 an hour and you're
barely making ends meet making 20 an
hour so we've got some financial stuff
we got to look at and then we need to
look at professionally where else can i
work as a mechanic and outside of a
dealer you know i go to a local mechanic
stacy and i take our cars to a guy and
they're not a big corporation a small
business and
you know i think there's some some good
people out there
that probably have enough work going
around to where you could find a much
better paying mechanic job than just a
really small shop i at least want to
challenge you on that to look for that
and consider that and i will just tell
you this quickly because i want dave to
address some of the financial stuff on
why you're not making ends meet and what
we can do there but i want to challenge
this this premise that all people are
going to judge you because of your legal
past a lot of people do and it's
unfortunate but the reality is is that
through relationships in your local
community there are enough people that
know who you are who you were
and who you are and how you've been
clean and how you're making a better
path and it's through relationships
that you will get opportunities because
as a mechanic right now this is a
wonderful time you can make a lot more
money than you're making right now even
if you take on a side hustle i i think
you can get to back in the forty dollar
range without working for a dealer i
think you're gonna get back with other
mechanical things so let me let me ask
you that how old are you
34. how long ago was the divorce
uh three years
okay
all right
so you're going to have a house so what
i'm hearing is dui and dry and divorce
all the three-year mark that was the
bottom wasn't it
yeah that was the bottom
i i my parents died in 2015
within like uh two years apart and then
i was basically spiraling down since you
know 2015. let me uh let me throw a
guess at you
i was 28
when i lost everything and went bankrupt
and it was my fault
the reason i went bankrupt is i was
stupid
and i signed a whole bunch of short-term
notes
and so after i went bankrupt i had to
recover financially but i also lost my
confidence
for a period of time
and then i started handling money god's
ways biblically common sense ways and i
started gradually rebuilding my
confidence but part of the process for
me
becoming valuable again in the
marketplace was to first forgive myself
and get over my past because i was
pretty stinking ashamed
and i kind of think that's holding you
back more than the actual marketplace is
holding you back
i think you're a stud i feel like i
deserve to make less because exactly
yeah because you lost your family you're
heroin you lost your mom and dad you had
a dui and this is your this is your
punishment well son your punishment's
over yeah as of today
you're no longer being punished
you're a stud listen dude anybody kicks
heroin is a superman
that is a tough one to bust
that's a tough one
that's no light weight that's not vaping
okay i mean that's serious crap
so you are a stud and you are coming
back and you are worth forty dollars an
hour because you can work on a car as
good or better than the other dubers
that are doing it for forty dollars an
hour
i know you may not be able to do the
test drive around the block you might
have to pay the guys next to you 50
bucks a week to do your test drives for
you and you sit in the passenger seat
and listen to the symptom then you go
back and turn the wrench i don't know
there's a way to skin this cat though
dude but it starts with you saying all
of the crap is in the rearview mirror
and it's smaller than the windshield
because it doesn't count as much
you're worth this man you can do i'm
trying to get
side hustles and stuff and uh you know
side work you know fixing cars for
people but you know because of all my
trouble you know my circle you know as
you know i don't have nick listen
expand your circle you just agree with
what dave said now act on it you believe
what he said now act on it expand your
circle go out right now the people that
do believe in you
ask for opportunity start fixing stuff
on the side anywhere and everywhere you
can you need to you need to have people
that when they look over on the across
your back they see a superman cape yeah
because that's who i see
you can do this young man you can do
this
and and i i understand i've had those
exact same feelings for different
reasons but had those exact same
feelings and i became valuable when i
started believing i was valuable again
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage kaylin
is with us hi kalyn how are you hello
i'm doing great dave how are you better
than i deserve welcome where do you live
i'm from oklahoma city i love oklahoma
city good town welcome to nashville how
much debt have you paid off 157 thousand
dollars
how long did this take took six years
but the last three years i paid off 136
000 of that so really 100 really three
years okay and your range of income for
the last three years um i started off
around 64. and now making about 90. good
what do you do for a living i'm a doctor
of audiology so cool i diagnose and
treat hearing loss balance disorders
got it cool yeah got a good one in my
life
we're good at some good hearing aids
because we're wearing these headphones
all my life yep so 30 years of these
things will blow your hearing out so
ah 157 000 what kind of debt uh so 40
000 of that was my vehicle 117 000 if
that was student loans ah okay
all right when did you get out of school
i graduated at university of oklahoma in
2016.
with your audiology degree that's
correct yes all right
and uh cool so three years ago you
kicked this into high gear what happened
i was actually living in birmingham
alabama at the time and i had just
gotten out of a really rough
relationship and i kind of just decided
i wanted to move back home and be closer
to family
and my mom said you know why don't you
just come back home live with me for a
little bit kind of get back on your feet
decide where you want to be what you
want to do
and she actually had followed a lot of
your stuff and had told me about the
debt snowball and
at that point i had not watched any of
your videos or anything like that but i
decided to go ahead and move back in
with my mom and she was gracious enough
to let me live there rent free so i was
able to put you know all of my check
toward my vehicle nice fresh start so
yeah it was good um i
basically just
started paying everything that i could
toward my vehicle and followed her
advice on the debt snowball and i paid
off my vehicle in march of 2020 three
years early
and fortunately for me um just by the
time i paid off my vehicles when cove
had hit yeah
and
the student loan interest rate went to
zero percent and it was a pause and i
just decided you know what i'm going to
take advantage of this and i'm going to
keep paying the student loans
that was kind of difficult to do because
there was a lot of talk about canceling
student loans and
i thought you know what if i pay all
this money and then they come back and
they cancel it
but i eventually kind of came to the
conclusion that that probably wasn't
going to happen anytime soon and i could
go ahead and get it paid off and so
that's what i did i paid 3 000 a month
on my student loans for basically the
last two years
and knocked that out pretty quick very
cool how does that feel that's amazing i
mean it really is amazing to see it go
down you know that quickly
and i got to be honest you know in the
beginning i was kind of doing what dave
refers to as financial peace-ish
so i was kind of still doing like a
single for life plan i had some money i
was trying to save for a house and i was
trying to
pay off my student loans at the same
time and
you actually came in early 2021 and you
preached at life church in oklahoma city
and that was where i got on board with
financial peace university and watched
the videos and kind of realized i was
doing this part way where i was putting
some money in one bucket and then using
the other money to try to pay down my
student loans and
about that time dallas and i reconnected
and um we're together now and uh he was
like you know dave says that you're not
supposed to do it that way like you're
supposed to go
down yeah
and he told me he's like you know you
need to stop saving for the house he
said you need to just put all of that
towards your student loan debt and and
get it paid off and um so that's what he
did so he's my fellow weird person and
it's really you know made a huge
contribution to me getting where i am
he's supported us we live together now
and he's supported us for the last seven
months um so that i could continue
paying my debt down and
so it's been fantastic well way to go
guys very cool very cool very proud of
you thank you and uh man you got to feel
kind of accomplished
i do i definitely do i mean like i said
i just i i think it's still kind of
surreal like it hasn't set in yet you
know like what what can you do with this
money that you have now it's like i've
been on such a
a track just hardcore you know trying to
just pay pay pay and all of a sudden
you've got all this income coming in and
you don't have any more debt it's like
you break through and now you can fly
yeah that's it exactly so um it's a
wonderful feeling and um you know we've
got plans now saving up for a wedding
and
it should be good i'm super excited
about what's to come and you know what's
what's coming next for our future so
yeah very good caitlin i want to ask you
what's the difference in the emotion of
having over a hundred thousand dollars
in student loans and wondering is the
government gonna pay it off and whatever
that emotion was for you however you
process that and now here you are on the
other side
and you've paid it off
and and now there's there's nothing
holding you back describe the difference
in the mindset now
it's just you know it's that feeling of
independence of you know i'm not relying
on somebody else to do this for me i
take a lot of pride in the fact that i
didn't wait on somebody else to do it
for me that you know i took control of
my life and i did it foreign
and um you know and i'm not waiting i'm
not sitting around waiting on somebody
else to do it for me or you know waiting
to see what's going to happen dr john
calls that uh mental health
mental health
you know where you are in control of
your life and you are in control of your
destiny and you know it that's a big
deal way to go
way to go what do you tell people the
biggest key to getting out of debt is
you just got to stick with it on the
days when it gets hard you have to keep
that which is most of them yeah it is i
mean you give up the small things but i
think you just have to keep the end in
mind about you know what's coming on the
other side of that and what you can do
once you don't owe that money anymore
it's a pain in the butt but now you make
100k with no payments so life's good you
know yes and planning a wedding yay life
is good good stuff well we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
also a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away to someone maybe
get them started on a journey like yours
and i'm also going to give you the
one-year subscription to financial peace
university awesome and uh if you haven't
been through it you guys go through it
as pre-marriage counseling together
and uh if not then if you have been
through it then give it away to someone
and sign somebody up so they can take
the trip that you've been on because
you've been on a good trip i'm proud of
you thank you very good stuff and i'm
sure uh when i pass on to pastor craig
groschel that it's all his fault he'll
be proud of you as well thank you
i always sent him an email when we tag
teamed on something good so that sounds
great yeah let him know because that's
that's where i heard all about you
that's where i did financial peace
university after that so um really dove
in head first after that sermon so thank
you for that well thank you thank you so
much kaylin from oklahoma city oklahoma
157
000 paid off in six years but in three
years 136 of it did it making 64-90
quite a journey count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream
three
two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
well done kiddo that is fabulous that's
about as good as it gets you guys open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and
your money the psychologists like dr
loney call it locus of control
when you are a person who feels like
that other people in other situations
control your life
you
lose an element of your mental health
because you've lost an element of i am
in control of my destiny now we all know
that things outside of us do impact us
that's it's absurd to think otherwise
but too many people give too much power
to something outside of themselves
to run your life an example of that is
i'm waiting on the government in some
method to fix my life forgive my student
loans or give me biden bucks or whatever
or whatever it is that's going to make
me okay if you're waiting on the
government to fix your life your life is
always going to suck
because pretty much every endeavor that
the government is involved in sucks
the only thing they do well
is national parks
they do a good job with those they're
great at borrowing money as well and
they and the military yeah and
as much as we love the military those in
the military will tell you they're not
very efficient
so you know
you don't want tho you don't want that
locus you don't want to turn over
control of your life to anyone else
that's exactly right you know this
empowerment this idea i am empowered
who's going to get my who's going to
straighten my life out me
the guy in my mirror
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
james is with us in chicago hi james
welcome to the ramsay show
[Music]
thank you sir i appreciate that i get to
talk to both of you gentlemen it's an
honor sure how can we help
well uh my wife and i have four kids
they are about eight five
three and 18 months
and we're trying to save up for our
first home and
we're struggling to make progress with
regards to a down payment that would
get us within that 15-year mortgage
quarter take-home pay uh boundary for
our first home purchase are you out of
debt
hello
james
i'm here are you out of debt
yes we are out of debt completely okay
and you have your emergency fund in
place
yes sir and your household income is
what
uh we clear about 6 200 a month after
taxes on average okay all right
so
did you pay off some debt already
yes sir we paid off about a hundred ten
thousand uh we got completely out of
debt how long did that take like that
about five years
okay so you're saving at a rate of about
twenty thousand dollars a year or you
are reducing debt at a rate of about
twenty thousand dollars a year
yes and part of that was selling off
some cars and vehicles uh some
uh
we had some gifts that enabled us to
clear some more debt so it wasn't uh
just our personal income
that paid off and got us out of debt but
at this point we can squeeze maximum 800
a month out of our out of our budget
you make a hundred thousand dollars a
year
and you can't find 10 grand
you're squeezing to get 10 grand i'm
really confused
are you doing a written budget
yes sir every dollar has a name and both
of you are agreeing to it
yes sir absolutely we've been doing it
faithfully that's how that's how we got
out of debt and that's that's how we're
living um where is all your money going
then since you know
so we have a two thousand dollar rent
payment
and then we have uh we had 550 a month
for school
the rest of it is basic living expenses
we live
in illinois
so our gas is a little bit higher
we spend about 900 a month on groceries
trying to think through what other
perhaps out of the ordinary expenses we
might have but those are those are the
main things uh we have to spend about
400 a month on on gas we've got a
minivan and i drive a a four cylinder
but
yeah that's that's more or less
where we're at we do a budget and we're
largely faithful to stick to it and
adjust accordingly if something
doesn't go right
okay
all right and so overall what's your
question
i need to i need a little bit of
direction on what i can do to increase
uh my income without burning my family
out
i said we've got four little kids
my wife does work part-time she's the
director of worship at our church and
i just um
i i don't know how to what i got to do
to accelerate the uh
what do you do for a little bit
i own a window cleaning business we do
commercial and residential window
cleaning okay
and are you a one-man gang you got some
employees how big is your your operation
i am a one-man band and um
that's
not the way it had always been uh
because our expenses have gone up for
our for our personal lives uh
i haven't
uh
i haven't felt that we could afford to
hire an employee just yet to help
lighten the load and yeah but the issue
for you is
increasing your client base that
includes that increases your revenue so
are you full are you maxed out as to
what you can do as far as window
cleaning
yeah just about i could maybe squeeze in
another five hours but i'm cranking out
50 55 hours and uh
you know we
uh
you could do more if you had some help
yes
so the help would pay for itself it's
you you're acting like a help is a net
cost
employees you should always make more
employees make more own employees than
they cost you that's how business works
yes yes that's correct however if i uh
my concern is that if i hire somebody
that's a
for a temporary season no no less uh
i would take a substantial dip in my
personal take-home pay
because we're like i said we're living
on a pretty well okay
are you a seasonal business
sort of about a third of our revenue is
seasonal uh
well then this is so here's the deal
here's what i hear on you i hear all
these limitations
i i hear roadblock after roadblock after
roadblock and i i don't see the
roadblocks so let me give you a really
practical example if you are seasonal i
talk to people all the time that are
killing it in seasonal businesses and
they hire seasonal help they pay them
very very well
and so i don't think that's a limitation
i think you're creating something in
your head if you paid somebody forty
thousand dollars seasonally to help you
and you made another hundred
that'd be okay yeah and then what can
you do in the off season
that is uh run the other 67 of the
revenue yeah plus what utility can you
bring to the table that's similar to
cleaning windows but it's a service
that's not seasonal you have skill and
you have experience that can be
leveraged to make more money in the off
season this is a function of you
deciding how important this is and get
after it i think the answer to your
question other words is to grow your
business yeah and you grow your top line
revenue
by growing the capacity of the business
the only way to do that is to add some
help
and that's why we call them help because
they help
and um
uh you know the quote hired help thing
you know there are people hired to help
you and i've you know they've become
part of your team they become friends
it's a small business it's a family
business it's a wonderful environment
for someone but i mean you could pay
somebody pretty well
out of the extra money that you're able
to have come in because you were able to
expand your capacity
i mean if you could clean
uh
40
30 more houses
windows because you had one more person
on your team and you were just that much
faster because of that
i don't think you're going to get to 50
more
but you probably could get to 30 to 40
percent more and so you move from
the top line of 100k to a you know a top
line of a hundred 150
or whatever and you pay the guy 30 or
40. i mean it's it's
doable dave i think there's a follow-up
that i think a lot of our listeners
would would benefit from and you can
speak to this very uniquely
there is some
fear
that is really holding him back there
this idea that employees are so
expensive and and the way you come at so
many things on the show is let's just
look at the math so for a small business
person who feels like they're the chief
everything officer and they can't grow
because they can't afford to hire
somebody what's the math process they
need to walk through real math and go
okay how i can actually walk this out
and see that it's not the big scary
monster under the bed what would you
recommend they do well there's two kinds
of team members you had
ones that are fixed expense and uh save
you money because they free you up
for instance i hired a personal
assistant years ago which meant i didn't
have to do all the documentation and all
the other stuff which meant i could be
doing something that made money so it
increased my ability my ability to make
money because i didn't have to do some
of the stuff okay so i offloaded some
things the other type of person is a
person who directly impacts revenue
that's the easiest one to hire that's
right because you know you're going to
cost me x and you're going to make y
and if you don't make y then you're not
going to cost me x because i can't keep
you
and so we're going to have to have the
first guy i hired russ carroll well we
brought him in he was here for 20 years
he's retired from here he's a wonderful
friend
i told russ i said you know he was going
to do financial coaching financial
counseling and i said i we need to get
some financial counseling in here or
your kids are going to be skinny
you know this was the conversation we
had right and so uh we had you know
because i can't pay you except we get
more money in here to pay you with dude
because there ain't no money here i mean
we we didn't have financial peace we
were teaching financial peace but we
didn't have financial fees you know and
so
that's the thing and so we just had to
work through that and and it worked out
obviously because russ was here for 20
years but you're right it is scary but
the easiest one to have to add is one
that adds more revenue than they cost
immediately
that puts us sour in the ramsey show in
the books
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
have actual amazing relationships we're
glad you're here thanks for joining us
ken coleman ramsey personality host of
the ken coleman show number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
mark's with us in springfield hey mark
welcome to the ramsay show
how you doing dave great man what's up
well i've got a question um i kind of
did some stupid stuff and uh
last year or a little bit over a year
ago i called into one of your other
shows that he's no longer with you so i
don't know if i need to if i can say his
name or not
um
okay well i call it was chris hogan and
uh
he gave me uh ramsay plus for a year
good well then
two days later you guys parted ways
and me and my infinite wisdom said well
this dave ramsey is an idiot i'm not
ever going to do anything with him so i
convinced my wife that dave ramsey is an
idiot
well now here i am a year and a half
later she got to talk to my wife
i don't think that would help him with
what he's now going towards then oh i
might be too outside
i got sidetracked okay
okay so anyway here i am a year and a
half later realized that you know my
infinite wisdom was not really with him
at all and
i needed to try and get back
on the dave ramsey program well the
problem is i've convinced my wife that
dave ramsey's an idiot and so now i'm
trying to
fix that and convince her that i was
wrong
and
i just i
i'm not sure that i'm doing a good job
of it um
she had we had one bill that i figured
if we could pay this off you know it
would it would get her to see
what was going on
but
all it did was get her to say well that
means that we can invest this money now
and we've still got 84 000
in debt not including the house
and
i know that we need to get that paid off
before the investing but she's worried
because she's got a lot of medical
issues and she doesn't know that she's
going to be able to live long enough to
be able to see retirement if we don't
start now
what's the nature of her medical issues
well she's got
type 1 diabetes um
when she's got a history of cancer like
every female in her family has died of
cancer but she does not have answers
because i had cancer
not yet no okay and how old are you but
she's
well i'm 40 and she's well i will be 40
in a couple months and she's 36. okay
well her thinking she's going to die
before she has wealth using our system
is asinine
okay she's not gonna die before she has
wealth unless she's a car wreck not from
what you've just described to me anyway
so that's her saying i don't believe you
that's not a truthful statement that's
hyperbole and drama
that's just her saying you know you've
been wrong so much i don't know which
time you were right that's all she's
saying
that's true what's your income mark
combined income or sole income uh we
have combined income uh our our
take-home income is just under a hundred
thousand okay so you got plenty of money
you just don't have a system how long
y'all been married
uh well we've been married for
just over a year like a year and a half
but we've been together for eight and a
half years okay all right well now
you're together and now you got to
decide what's the next 20 years look
like
and so
the the thing i i would take dave ramsey
ken coleman chris hogan out of the
equation
i don't think i don't think they're
relevant to your life in in terms of the
actual people involved there that's
we're not relevant the question is
what's the vision yeah for euros future
and i um
i think you sit down and you look out
there into the future
and you say all right let's turn off the
tv
let's set everything aside set all the
bills aside let's set all the worries
about medical aside
and let's say
okay when we're 65
when we're 70 what do we want our life
to look like
and write those things down
that's called a vision
okay and get really detailed high def
television hd
okay
and then the two of you look at that and
and let's talk about that long enough
and don't tell her what her vision is
ask her
what her vision is
and then she needs to ask you and the
two of you talk to talk it through until
you go okay so out of all the things we
wrote down here the most important thing
we're both saying is this and the next
most important thing is this and you say
okay we'd like to have a million dollars
and we'd like to be traveling the world
we'd like to have no debt
that'd be an example okay
when you when you're 65. i'd like to
have the money to travel and enjoy my
life i don't know if you want to travel
or not i just made that up okay but
whatever it is you write down what we
want to do is okay and then you say all
right now
and then my friend henry cloud says
that's your desired future
then you have to ask yourself what has
to be true
that is not true today
for us to be there then
well we got to shed 84 000 worth of debt
we have to start saving money we have to
start living in control and quit
spending like we're in congress
right
that's what has to be true for you to
get to that dream
now what is the method week next
question is what is the method we use
to get rid of 84 000 in debt quit
spending like we're in congress be in
agreement on our spending uh and be
investing steadily so that we have a
million dollars we can travel the world
we're 65.
and we have no debt
um
what is the easiest method to do that
what's the most proven method to do that
oh there's a thing called financial
peace university
we could go through that and watch that
together and see after we watch it if we
think that that is the best way for us
to get to our desired future
10 million people have gone through the
class
okay
10 million people have gone through the
glass
if it was screwing people if we were
ripping people off
somewhere around a million someone would
have said this is a rip-off
we get no complaints about it being
rip-off
the only complaints we get is is the
stuff we tell people to do is hard
but it works
every
time you work it
to the extent you work it so
first you decide where it is you want to
go then you decide how i want to get
there and then you decide who can guide
me the quickest to get on my journey
and i'm convinced that the ramsey
organization as a whole
not me personally but financial peace
university the steps we teach is the
fastest
right way
to become wealthy
and i'll give you another year
of ramsay plus of financial peace
university for you guys to sit down and
watch that together but you can't just
do that on the basis of dave ramsey's a
good guy dave ramsey's not a bad guy
or dave ramsey he's a bad guy ramsay's a
good guy or i don't like you know i
don't like chris hogan left i don't like
you can't that doesn't decide your
future
that decides dave ramsey's future chris
hogan's future ken coleman's future but
but your future is decided by what you
do
and so you got to decide what you're
going to do
and if if i've lost credibility in your
household because hogan left then so be
it it's okay
find you a way though dude
find you a proven path to get there
because it didn't happen unless you guys
do it and you do it together
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today a lot of people would
rather spend their weekend doing yard
work than talk about insurance have a
root canal than talk about insurance
there's a lot of bad things we would do
but talk about insurance but here's the
deal if you don't take the time to learn
about insurance you're going to get
ripped off and you're always going to
feel like you're getting ripped off
because you're really getting ripped off
around here we think learning about
money should be simple or even fun our
new free
five-day guide to insurance called
confidence in your coverage makes
learning about insurance quick and
practical and you might even laugh out
loud a time or two it is after all
ramsey personality george campbell which
is always good for a laugh to top it off
we're doing a giveaway for the folks who
sign up at the end of the series you'll
still have the artwork but at least
you'll know your stuff when it comes to
insurance go to ramseysolutions.com
confidence
get signed up for the free five-day
guide to insurance confidence in your
coverage
ramseysolutions.com
confidence
jasmine's with us in washington dc hi
jasmine welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
how are you all
better than we deserve what's up
um so i am a single mother i'm on baby
step two but also trying to stay for a
house
um unfortunately i have about 30 000 in
debt um between one credit card and two
loans
i had uh you know done step one the one
thousand dollar fund but then i sold a
vehicle and now i have an extra 11 000
and i just need some guidance in terms
of
where to put that i'm going to be
putting my daughter in daycare soon so
that's a monthly expense that's kind of
been
thinking i might need to save up for as
well but i'm you can't save up for a
monthly expense you got to be able to
cover it with your income what's your
income true
so about 34
000 or not thousands 3 400 a month net
i'm getting a second job to help
supplement for that very reason you just
said
um so but in the meantime i've just been
dipping into it and i don't want to dip
into it for that reason who's watching
your daughter now
um my parents but once she's a year ah
she's going to daycare
oh i'm sorry when
when when she's a year old
daycare i see okay so they kept her as
an infant and now that she's eligible
for daycare i see for your daycare yeah
okay
all right so you're making
fifty thousand dollars a year give or
take plus your side hustle
okay and you've got thirty thousand
dollars in debt do you have anything
saved for the house yet
i know i because i was dipping into it
to try and pay for so you don't have
anything right now you don't have a
house fund today
no just the uh what i sold for the car
right right okay and the 30 000 in debt
is what
what kind of debt
so 4 500 is on the credit card
um and then there's a small 5 000 dollar
loan but then the bigger loan is the 20
thousand dollar loan on what
um
the 20 000 another car loan
no no no these were loans i got
previously to pay off old order cards
from before so i've just been paying
them off for the past
couple years so you figured out this
borrowing your way out of that thing
doesn't work
exactly yeah have you cut up the credit
card
yes i don't use it no i didn't ask that
i said did you cut it up
yeah put it in a shredder
like scissors
like destroyed it oh
uh i just used the shredder to put it in
there oh you put in the shredder okay
that'll work
that works good okay i'm just making
sure the thing's gone because it keeps
biting you and i don't want this snake
in your house
right okay even when you're asleep it
bites you you're gonna be careful
okay so
um
you getting child support
no why there's no income from the other
side
um
that's a whole other issue i don't know
why they're not employed but
that's a all right i believe i would ask
the judge to help me get some child
support out of uh
the
gentleman so he can uh learn to work
again it'll be good for him and taking
care of his own child would be like a
manly thing to do and stuff so yeah we
ought to do that now let's move on
though uh the
okay you're not buying a house yet
so just house is off the table no
you don't we only worry about saving up
for a house we need to worry about
getting out of debt you got 11 thousand
dollars i want you to take that down to
1 000 that means you have 10 000 and i
want you to pay off some of these debts
your smallest debt to your largest debt
and then i want you to get on a written
detailed game plan and i want you to put
every dollar you can squeeze out of your
life you are not allowed to go out to
eat you're not allowed to go even go
into a restaurant unless you work there
okay you're not allowed to go on
vacation you're broke
and you have a little tiny baby and
you're scared
freak
it is scary i know you're a warrior
princess i'm proud of you but you guys
you got a hill to climb here girl you
can do this and i'll help you i'm i'm
i'm your biggest cheerleader i love you
i think you're awesome
but you're going to be on scorched earth
where your broke friends think you're
crazy
your mother thinks you need counseling
because all you do is work and pay bills
and because you are on a mission to get
out of debt your freaking hair is on
fire
right this is the can you hear the roar
in my voice
i am loving it i'm trying to install it
into your throat
okay i want you to have that same kind
of ah i'm done right and and so i ain't
living like this i'm about to break this
i'm about to change my whole family tree
right now this kid of mine is going to
have life different because of the
decisions i make in the next 12 months
boom exactly yeah you're going to work
like a maniac for a short period of time
and you clear up all this debt now you
don't have any payments and you have a
written budget where you're living on
less than you make you got a whole new
life right there and then we can save up
a good emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then we can talk
about saving up for a house that's three
years from today
it's very doable um because you're gonna
be three years older anyway you might as
well be winning
of course
so should i so you're saying just throw
what i have at the for the credit card
and the small loans yes and then i'll
just chip away that big one yes yeah but
let's let's get practical jazz because
dave just gave a great great
motivational speech but do you see how
quickly you can pay off twenty thousand
dollars if that's the only one left with
that additional income that you're
making and then anything else you do do
you see if you put just a thousand
dollars a month towards that twenty
thousand that's twenty months max that's
if you just put a thousand you need to
put two thousand because you can do more
than that i want you to put two thousand
towards it because you're gonna get a
thousand out of your existing budget
you're gonna make an extra thousand
we're putting that whole 2000 towards
this and you're done in ten months
now how does that feel jasmine
that's gonna feel great this time next
year you got eight thousand dollars in
the bank and no payments
that would be fantastic that's where i
want you to be that's the goal and i
want you to sit down and write all of
that out now if i give you the free
class to go to financial peace
university will you do the class if i
give it to you free
absolutely okay now when you are a rich
and victorious
single mom someday i want you to find
one that's got a brand new baby you
scared out of her bones and you and you
buy it for and pay for it then okay
absolutely you're gonna pay it forward
later okay
yeah all right you hang on we'll take
care of you honey you call me anytime
and we'll help you with this you can do
this you can do this
but you this is the day when you start
happening to this life instead of this
life start happening to you
because
you get the snot beat out of you in
those situations and you just start to
want to curl up in the corner and say
don't kick me again
life i want to highlight dave what i'm
glad you said this uh you said get after
that judge and she needs to she
shouldn't feel guilty or obnoxious
that there is if there is a legal order
here on what this deadbeat is doing or
should be doing i'd like that advice go
after the judge
make that judge so put out with with
whatever she's doing that he goes after
this guy with everything he's got
because that is that is not right i'm
glad you brought that up well i mean
yeah
yeah we have a manhood crisis
big time the wussification of america
is real there's a crisis of manhood in
america it's unconscionable this guy's
not working in today's world an economy
and you have a brand new baby
you're freaking chocolate 15 an hour
working at night your only reason for
being on the planet right now bubba i
mean you made a baby you take care of
the baby this is how life works
man ups wuss
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality open
phones is my co-host open phones here at
triple eight eight two five
five
two two five charles is with us in
bowling green kentucky hey charles how
are you
[Music]
better than what the world says i should
be
hear you how can i help
uh i'm seeking wise counsel
my mother has cancer
and
we
we've already prayed about this and we
have you know we've determined it's her
time
so the problem is all her debt
so
uh just trying to get some idea how to
honor her
you know you know
so my dad and i can you know properly
honor her
i'm so sorry
how old is she
uh she's 69. okay and your dad and her
are still married
yes
okay and how much debt does she have hun
uh so there's 20 000 225 on the car
uh
four to five thousand on medical debt
that's
we're still getting some of the bills on
that
and then she has a ten thousand two
hundred dollar judgment from credit card
debt
okay do they own a home
yes
okay what's it worth
uh
considering the shape it's in probably
closer to 1 30 it needs something
i want it
zero so they are they own the home okay
do they have any money
uh about four thousand your dad does
yeah okay does she have any life
insurance
no
okay
and what is the prognosis
uh since you all have decided
uh that treatment is stopping if she's
got a month or a year or what are you
thinking
that that's the big unknown it's it's
acute leukemia so it's pretty much
whenever she runs out enough blood to
keep her alive yeah okay
but what's the doc saying
they they couldn't give us an estimate
on that
i mean it
it could have been it
it's pretty much a range of weeks to a
year okay okay
i'm so sorry i'm sorry you all are going
through this
okay rule number one is uh we don't
worry about the money part
we worry about mom first
okay and your dad just love them
the time that she's got here
you're pleasant you're not stressed
she's not stressed you're just going to
hang
okay
and been doing that and doing that
but the you can the the thing about this
stuff is it it um
you can get down into the business
aspects and the math aspects of
uh the work the adult work that has to
be done here and lose the enjoyment of
the little time you got left with her
and i don't want you to do that okay
that's not an issue i mean there are
times that i can i i just spent a couple
hours in the hospital with her okay now
if it helps me if i'm in these
situations to know the technical aspects
because it helps me lower my
anxiety or my stress level about
something because you're usually more
stressed about things you don't
understand than things you do understand
even if there's bad news in the things
you do understand agreed
yeah so here's how this works
mathematically so i'm going to get
technical and cold all of a sudden with
you you ready
yep okay
when when someone passes away
what they own
their assets has to stand good
for what they owe
if they own nothing
the debt does not transfer to their
children
now in your case your mom owns half of a
house
that's worth a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars
your mom
everything yeah go ahead everything else
is in her name only doesn't matter a
house it doesn't matter her house has to
stand good for her debt
so if your dad wants to keep this house
he's going to pay
her debt
right
okay if if there was not if they if they
lived in an apartment and they owned
nothing
then he would not have to pay a dime of
this because it's all in her name
and it does not even go across marriage
lines individuals or individuals in this
situation
okay but because she owns a house that's
where she owns a portion of a house
that's worth 130 000
if he wants to keep his portion of that
house he's going to have to
pay these debts so what are we going to
do we're going to sell the car
we're going to call the medical people
up and we're going to call the credit
card people up and go uh she died here's
a death certificate
and you send them a copy of the death
certificate and you say
we're willing to pay something on this
but she died
and her estate consists of an old house
that's not worth much
and um you know we're willing to settle
this and you go in and you settle this
fifteen thousand dollars worth of debt
for five or six thousand dollars and you
your brothers and sisters probably gonna
have to help your dad scrape that
together to do that and then he's gonna
when you write those checks and you
settle those debts
he's gonna have a free and clear hundred
and thirty thousand dollar house and no
debt
go and sell the car today
yeah uh yeah it's uh right now yeah you
know
just doing it on carvana that's like 17
000. private sale is somewhere in the
range of what it's like to 26 on the
high end so you can sell it for 20.
you got to find it you told me it's
worth you should tell me 20's owed on it
so you need to get you need to get the
car sold you get the car sold now
she doesn't need the car and then you're
sitting there on the other debt and you
just let it sit there and you don't do a
thing with it until
uh
until she graduates to heaven and after
she graduates then you go and you do
these business transactions
and you settle these debts
for
25 to 50 cents on the dollar with cash
and that clears your data out they've
been talking to the hospitals and
getting them to negotiate and reduce
that debt already good you're on you're
on track this is exactly what you do but
you don't get to walk away from it
because we need to protect the house for
your dad okay
yeah
if there was no house and she owned
nothing we would just call up the credit
card company and send them a death
certificate and say
she passed she has no assets you get
nothing you send them a letter
it'd be that simple okay
but in this case to protect dad's house
we've got to go through and settle these
things
okay so my first priority is vehicle get
rid of it then we start focus on medical
and then that judgment and i'm not
worried about those credit cards they
can just sit because there's they're not
going to do anything
they're just gonna sit they're gonna
squawk
but other than yell and flopping the
floor they're not gonna do anything just
sit on them and let them get old and let
them get nastier and then you can deal
with them next year
two years from now whenever you want to
deal with them so they don't come over
and put a lien on your dad's house we
eventually want to take care of them
right
yes is your dad working
no he he's unable to work okay he's had
a couple strokes and
injuries
okay and your brothers and sisters
no
it's we're all single children okay what
do you make
i make 52. i've
i've already started uh
the 225 a month that i normally put away
into my savings i've already started
diverting that to help them
okay but yeah for me all i have is you
know my only debt to the house and i've
already got 12 month
savings and all that well i mean if you
took a little bit of your savings and
settle this debt
that'll be fine because you're going to
inherit this other house someday anyway
right uh eventually although i'm
probably gonna suck because i don't know
i didn't say that you're gonna but
you're gonna get 130 000 if your dad
passed away today so if you put five
thousand dollars in this deal to help
your dad it's not like you lost it
you're protecting your future asset
again i'm being very cold and calculated
here and i'm taking all the feelings out
of this because we understand that
there's more important things in all
this junk we covered that in the first
part of our conversation
but um yeah
i'm sorry you guys are facing this
charles it's so hard to go through
and um that that's a
a nasty disease right there man it's
slow
it's it's harsh
i'm sorry
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
thanks for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today crystal's in cleveland ohio hi
crystal how are you
hi dave good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
[Music]
so my husband and i um last year we were
making nearly six figures
blowing through our debt doing great
and my two-year-old while he was one at
the time a one-year-old son
unexpectedly started having
seizures so
it was a long process we're still
struggling we have
lots of doctor's appointments all the
time but how's he doing he made the
decision
he's doing better much better um did the
diagnosis coming down
they diagnosed it he has something
called gray matter heterotopia um they
found a spot in his brain that shouldn't
be there basically so
it's been emotional
yeah i guess we made the decision for
just my own emotional
state um i was a school teacher and we
made the decision for me to stay home
so that's understandable we
yeah we basically cut our income in half
that our expenses were the same so we
blew through our emergency fund and
pretty much all of the debt that we had
paid off accrued again
um
so we're looking at where where
gazelle's
mindset but we don't know what our next
step should be
so we have a few reasons
have you adjusted your lifestyle now to
be within his income or are you still
going in the hole
we're we've adjusted all the extra stuff
out but just our mortgage
um so you have to sell your house in
order to stay home be with your child
yes when's it going up for sale
should have gone up for sale the first
day you came home from school
absolutely my husband doesn't want to
sell i don't care
so i don't care what your husband wants
you guys you guys already made this
choice you made the right choice we're
going to stay home with the baby the
baby's so sick
my heart is breaking and i have tears
running down my face and i'm going to
stay home with my baby my baby is sick
we cut our income in half you can't
ignore the fact that you have to also
cut your expenses in half simultaneously
and you didn't do that right
the first part you did was heroic the
second part you did was stupid
sell your house
okay
for your child for your child sell your
house
right you can't afford your house on
your husband's income
am i right
yes okay
all right
the house is a um
it is uh collateral damage
to the situation with your child and
what you're declaring when you do this
is that you spending time and being
there for this sick baby is more
important than the stupid house
exactly
because you cannot live in a fantasy
mathematically
you don't get a pass on math
because you're a hero for a sick baby
you should be a hero for a sick baby
you're an amazing woman he's an amazing
guy you got a hard tough situation i'm
sorry you're facing this but do not make
it worse
mom my concern is right now um
our debt to income
even if we sold our home i'm
i guess to sell to purchase another home
i mean we would have
a decent we have a decent amount of
equity what what is your what is your
house payment
um our house payment is a little over
1100 and what is his take-home pay
his base take home a month is only 1800
but he makes commission on top of that
and it very
greatly what does he make a month
right now um
his take-home is 1800.
he's not making anything above the 1800
a month
right now he is um
last month let me see
um
last month he brought home three
thousand
you cannot
something has to change and here's the
thing something's going to change
you're either going to change it or
somebody's going to change it for you
called a foreclosure
in a bankruptcy
because you're you're driving a car
straight at the wall mathematically
aren't
you yeah
you you you are in denial about the fact
that the math sucks
with the fact that the baby being sick
is sucks
yes
and the man it causes the math to suck
and you can't you gotta face the whole
thing
it's your best way through this
your best way to win long term is to
face the whole thing and what's going to
happen i can tell you i'm i'm i'll just
be a prophet are you ready
five years from today this is the five
years from today
the seizures will be gone
he's gonna be a normal little boy
running around like crazy and you're
gonna be back teaching and this is all
going to be in your rear view mirror but
it's going to be in your rear view
mirror faster if you deal with the
present
full reality today
okay
crystal you said earlier that the reason
you came home from the classroom was for
your emotional well-being
and yet all of this debt
is causing just as much emotional stress
so you've got to implore your husband to
understand that we made this decision
for my emotional and mental well-being
and yet i'm not getting the benefits of
that because of our finances and this is
a season
and you don't need to be thinking about
a house you sell the house
and you rent and this is a circle the
wagons moment for your family where we
circle the wagons and we defeat the
enemy in front of us and then
you're going to get another home
explorer
you're not going to get one on 3 000 a
month yeah
right and you're not going to get one in
this current situation whoopty dumpty
there's another house i've been to
cleveland ohio there's houses all over
the place you can get you another house
right
they're everywhere yeah and so you'll
get you another one yeah this is this is
a moment in time this is what's known as
the valley
you are in the valley right
but the point of valley is you don't
stay there you're not going to live your
whole life in the valley it doesn't turn
it doesn't work out that way
and
so this is the thing you'll look back on
and you'll tell
you know you'll tell your little boy's
kids someday you know when your kid your
daddy was worn he about drove us nuts we
had to sell the house oh
you know
you're gonna be that you'll be that
grandmother telling that story right
that's what's gonna happen crystal i
can't tell you how many times my mom and
dad have talked about when i came into
this world they live in this teeny tiny
one bedroom see now there's a whole
nother thing over a pharmacy yeah
but the point is that you talk about how
hard it is
well imagine trying to parent me for
heaven's sakes but you know this is a
season and i don't remember it your
son's not going to remember it
and and and this is a storm
this is a storm right now and
i got to tell you it's not for your
emotional well-being you're being a good
mom that's right a good mom wants to be
there with a one-year-old that's having
seizures
that's just a good mom yeah i mean
that's not a bad thing thank you and if
you were my own kid i would tell you to
do exactly what you're doing except for
the part where you kept all the expenses
right
so those got to go starting today and
then you'll come back out of this and
you'll be able to add a house back and
you'll be able to now the last thing of
this is i want to ask you this
how available with this medical
situation are you
to do tutoring in your own home
um we've talked about that even um for
this next upcoming school year like 40
an hour schedule
yeah make a huge difference if you can
if you have the bandwidth and it doesn't
put your child in jeopardy
right i'm not trying to have you quit
work and turn and put you back to work i
wasn't was trying to do but i am but if
there's some bandwidth while kiddo is
sleeping or kiddo is manageable 99 of
the time but we're just here to watch
him yeah and make sure he's not having
an episode right then then you can do
some 40 an hour
uh tutoring and you can change this
whole situation and maybe keep the house
yeah i would tell you a very specific
idea there dave is online teaching adult
education makes really good money and
the little guy's in sleep she's got the
mom you're in control of when you do it
yeah yeah
online online tutoring big time help
yeah check on all that but kiddo make
the adjustments on the out go when you
make the adjustments on the income
that's what i want you to do so you win
in this you call us anytime we'll be
honored to help
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsay show we help people
build wealth
do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author host of the ken
coleman show
is my co-host today
thank you for being with us open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five annie is in minneapolis hi
annie how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's
up well thank you for taking my call
so last week i sold my house
and later today i'm going to get the
profits from that sale deposited into my
account and it's going to be 73 000
i'm a registered nurse i'm a single mom
i'm 28 years old and at the moment i
don't have any savings um i do have 44
000 in debt and so my plan was to pay
off the debt and then
i would have 27 000 left over and i know
that that's not um a ton but i i guess
i'm just wondering um the best way to to
steward that you know if it's savings or
if it's retirement or um just kind of
what what to do with that
what do you make
um
so monthly after taxes and including
child support is 4 000 a month
you said you're a nurse
yes
okay
what kind of nurse
um i work from home at the moment um i
was previously working in the clinic but
with the pandemic i took a work from
home job doing medication refills
for no money
you took a pay cut
the 4 000 a month yeah i mean
i would yeah you're an underpaid nurse
that's why i was asking okay
typical nurse is making 60 to 80 grand
right now
you're making 35 or 40.
well
that's that's after taxes and and
everything um because it's 34 an hour
and i work over 40 hours a week
okay what's coming out of your check
um
you got health insurance coming on your
check
yes how much and then i'll
um you know i don't actually have the
exact number um i i chose the
highest tier so it's more expensive
yeah how many kids you should
one what age
nine where are you living now that you
sold your house
um i am renting
just got an apartment
yes okay
all right
okay
um
well here's the thing i think you've
chosen an incredible career don't you
ken i think so she has the sky's the
limit there and i think you're getting
um
mediocre to poor results on your career
i think you can make a lot more money
without destroying your life you have a
nine-year-old
and um
because i you know five years from today
you're gonna be sitting right here
unless you save some money for a down
payment right
yes why'd you sell the house
i had taken out a first time home buyers
loan and um i wanted to get out of that
i didn't know whether i should refinance
or sell but just being the way that the
market was i wanted to
kind of take advantage of how much that
the home had gone up in value okay so
you can clear all these debts and you've
got no debt now
and if we can maximize your career you
can use the 27 000 to first put an
emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses aside for your rainy day
fund then the rest of it we throw to
start your new house fund your new house
down payment saving fund we're gonna
separate the two because you don't need
a 27 000 emergency fund in your
situation you need maybe 15 okay
um
and so you got 10 or 12 to put in a
thing and then let's get your income up
and get you on a budget a detailed plan
now that you don't have any payments to
rebuild a good emerge or a good down
payment and buy a house a couple three
years from now what do you think
yeah i think that sounds really good
yeah ken what do you think about this
career yeah i mean you're making around
65 000 a year is that sound about right
to you
based on what you told us you know so
you know what does upward mobility look
like for you uh as an rn and a single
mom because here's the good news today
you're out of debt you got your
emergency fund your three month
emergency fund set up you're ready to go
and so now it's okay what kind of goals
do i have
and then what finances excuse me what
financial growth can i now add to that
picture because if you could be making
80 85 or more and set yourself up for a
great future all of a sudden you're
you're playing some serious serious ball
now and catching up big time with
investing and you're in really good
shape for a single mom so i do want you
to at least challenge yourself to say
okay what could my rn career look like
based on where i want to be financially
how does that the income play into it
because you've got a lot of options on
how to use a nursing degree to make
money in the open market
hey i'm still concerned about your
take-home pay okay
because if you're making 65 and you're
only taking home 36
um there's something wrong with these
numbers
okay because you don't have 30 000 in
tax withholding how much your stinking
health insurance premium
um well i think that it is oh you said
you're 300 a month you said you didn't
know that's right yeah i'm not exactly
sure okay i think you need to look at
that yeah because i think you bought the
lowest deductible most expensive health
insurance plan because you're a single
mom and you're a little bit afraid
yeah and i think you need to get a big
butt deductible you got 27 000 in the
bank
and get that premium down
and look at like is are you and the
nine-year-old both healthy
yes okay yeah let's get a big old
deductible like an hsa
like a five or seven thousand dollar
deductible whatever they've got and
let's get this premium down to about
four or five hundred six hundred bucks a
month because i think you're paying 14
1500 bucks are you getting a big tax
refund as well
uh it was 5 000 this year which is the
most it's ever been okay yeah you need
to change your w-2 then because you got
too much coming out for taxes
okay yeah what is the child supply 5 000
a year 600 bucks a month too much coming
out of your check
that's part of where this money is going
because basically you're you know you
got 30 000 bucks coming out of your
check before you get the money home am i
hearing that right
yeah yeah you're getting home with 36
000 and you made 65.
so your health insurance your
withholding is there anything else
coming out of your check are you were
you paying any of these bills out of
your check like was your car in there
and it was at the credit union or
something
no it's um also i have an amount going
into retirement as well how much
um
i i'm not exactly sure i know i had set
that up when i started working but um i
want you to get down in your numbers
again
you have to know your numbers about
where your what your health insurance
costs what you're getting what you're
putting in this uh retirement and let's
get this stuff straightened out because
you got your checks getting slayed
before it gets to you and i don't know
where it's going if i'm you
hang on i'm going to sign you up for
financial peace university we're going
to teach you how to handle money kiddo
and we'll show you exactly what to do
you call us anytime you need some help
because i think you've got the tools
right at your fingertips to really
prosper and i think you made a good move
selling this house it was a very hard
move emotionally but i'm glad you did it
i think you leap frog ahead if you get
these other things under control
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
guys if you're wondering whether to buy
or sell a home this year we got some
answers you can expect the market to be
similar to last year peak prices are
still going up they're not going down
you don't need to be sitting i'm waiting
on prices to come down you're gonna be
waiting a long time maybe they're not
coming down okay prices are not coming
down in real estate you just tell
tell people you heard dave ramsey say
right here prices and real estate are
not coming down
now what we are going to see is the
market's going to slow down
and we're going to quit having 10 buyers
for every house that's for sale
and so it's going to soften
and the craziness out of these every
house that goes on the markets a
freaking auction is going to go away
that's going to stop
this white hot market that we've had for
the last two years is going to stop but
interest rates are going up we're
heading into a recession it's going to
slow down it's not it's not a
catastrophe it's not the end of the
world and if you're gonna buy a house in
a situation like this this is a good
time to buy a house
if you are ready to buy a house if
you're out of debt you have your
emergency fund you have your down
payment i'm going to wait until the
prices don't weigh
prices next year going to be higher than
they were this year and the year after
that they're going to be higher than
that if you're ready to buy now is the
time to buy
and here's what's weird
if you're ready to sell
this is a great time to sell you can't
always say that
usually one or the other but you can't
always say both but right now it's a
unique market it is a great time to sell
like that last lady that we just talked
to she saw she got out while they
getting is good but you know if you're
gonna
prices are up compared to three years
ago but you can't go back to three years
ago if you're a buyer you got about a
day
and
they're not coming back down so hey if
you
you're my uncle charlie just got his
real estate license
good god this is your largest purchase
ever your uncle charlie knows about this
much more than about real estate than
you do get away from uncle charlie he's
sweet we love uncle charlie don't buy a
house from him get it buy a house from a
pro
that knows what the flip they're doing
list your most expensive asset that you
have with somebody who sells 100 houses
a year not somebody who just got their
license and is a friend of the family
and used to cut hair three weeks ago
jeez people
come on
seriously uncle charlie poor guy i mean
he's a lovable guy we love uncle charlie
not your real estate agent no well
ramsay solutions.com agent get a high
octane high protein agent that's been
vetted by us that gets the freaking job
done you don't this is not amateur hour
you need
you need somebody in your corner that
knows what they're doing our question
today comes from blinds.com they have a
100 satisfaction guarantee that means
even if you miss measure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free free samples free shipping new
promos they run all the time you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal today's
question comes from tyler in south
carolina i'm 20 years old and have been
watching the show for some time i'm
wondering what the best way is to get
into land development real estate
development i'm currently trying to
decide if i should go back to school and
get a degree in either finance or
construction management but i also know
that school is not always
the way to be successful amen to that
tyler but i have to seed the balance of
my time to the gentleman from antioch to
my left who's done real estate uh dave
does he need a degree would it help him
if he wants to eventually get into land
development or real estate development i
would question that what do you say
i spent a little time with a developer
the other day that is finishing up a 40
million dollar residential development
um he's got a degree in accounting
he's very successful
as a developer
uh there's a lot of moving parts and a
lot of bureaucrats to deal with
called a planning commission
called zoning all these things and city
people that you work with if you're
going to be a developer
and there's a bazillion numbers involved
so a degree in finance or construction
management or accounting would be very
helpful
to do something that is as complicated
as land development uh having said that
tyler um i will tell you that the most
risky
category of all real estate investment
is real estate development
more people go broke doing that than any
other kind of real estate
the most risky and if you want to really
make sure you go broke put a golf course
on it
it'll make you go broke every time
the second guy that buys that the one
that always makes the money golf courses
and ski slopes the second guy who buys
it out of bankruptcy are always the ones
that make money and the first one just
you know turns his dream into a
nightmare so at 20 years old you're not
going to be a developer if you're smart
you're going to spend a lot of time
studying your craft you're going to be
working for a developer that's the key
you're going to spend this is a this is
the type of industry that you need to
spend 10 years
in apprenticeship before you
actually do a deal
yeah i would add that dave you know if
you believe in the degree there it's
going to give you some real knowledge
that's great but i got to tell you the
school of hard knocks is also a
wonderful school and going to work for
men and women who are winning in this
field
where you can watch how they run the
business head on a swivel so while
you're going to school uh i'd be working
uh if you can't for a developer
absolutely even if it's summers and get
a real estate license and sell sell the
lots for them i love that go to work for
them get every angle from this this side
of it take the uh take the desk job
where you work with the bureaucrats and
help push the zoning through yeah um get
a degree in engineering or accounting or
uh even architecture
because you're going to need all of
those things when you're developing
property it's uh i mean you're putting
in streets and sewers
and lights and water and you're putting
in uh
you know amenities to go with the
development or not
you're making all these decisions you're
getting all the zoning done there's so
many moving parts in it it's a very very
high risk endeavor
and um i can tell you i've been doing
real estate over 30 years i grew up in
the real estate business
and i can count on one hand the number
of people that were doing developing
when i started
that are still doing development yeah
it's tough it's just it's it's it's it's
just a
it's a real quick way to go out and to
get to get taken out jordan's with us in
vancouver hey jordan welcome to the
ramsay show
hey thank you so much for having me
appreciate it sure how can we help
uh long story short uh it has to do with
cars and money i'm pretty sure familiar
with that topic um basically a friend
sold me a lemon of a car and i'm trying
to figure out if it's something that i
should be fighting to get some sort of
compensation back for if it's something
worth jeopardizing the friendship over
because
they kind of basically ended up saying
that hey sorry kind of sucks but uh not
really my problem i feel like they've
jeopardized the friendship so
at this point you don't worry about
jeopardizing anything
yeah let's see you screwed me and i
jeopardize the friendship i don't think
that's how that works um
the uh so he knew the car was bad
no uh to my knowledge i i don't think he
really had any idea that the car was
rough or in rough shape the problem is
is that within less than a week of
owning it less than 100 kilometers put
on it
it it completely died and ended up
needing to get completely scrapped for
for scrap metal
uh about 3 300
so how in the world did you have no idea
that this car was on its last breath
uh it was a deep engine problem
basically we did a full pre-purchase
inspection kind of passed with flying
colors
what kind of car is this
uh it's a 2002 monster tribute
and when you say deep engine problem
you're telling me that the mechanics
that did the inspection they didn't hear
any kind of engine knocking at all
nothing no kind of sound that would give
some type of clue there's some engine
issues
so i'm not sure if there's a difference
between between canadian american
pre-purchase inspection but they didn't
actually take the vehicle on a test
drive they just looked at it from sort
of an outside perspective like taking
the externals of the vehicle and kind of
you know putting up on the hood and kind
of taking a look at it but they didn't
actually take it for a test drive yeah
well i can just tell you i don't know
much about cars but i know that if you
take a a car for a test drive uh and
there's a deep engine issue that about a
week later 150 miles or kilometers later
something goes wrong there are signs of
that i can tell you that i i recently
bought a car did that did an inspection
i was going to buy an old car to flip it
and got rid of it so you don't think
that your buddy had any idea the car was
bad
no we actually took uh we actually took
it for a test drive with him like on two
separate questions it's not his fault
it's not his fault he doesn't owe you a
thing exactly he doesn't owe you a thing
correct
so you just lost 3 300 bucks because you
bought a bad car
that's answered your question
but your buddy didn't do anything wrong
yeah he didn't he didn't dupe you and he
does not he's not a car manufacturer he
doesn't warranty a 3 000 car
now
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book from
paycheck to purpose
is my co-host today tom and jennifer are
with us
they are in north carolina hi guys how
are you i see you're debt-free congrats
thank you very much hey dave how are you
better than we deserve brother how much
did y'all pay off
uh 175 000 dave cool how long did this
take
about
five total years five years okay and
your range of income during that time
so it ranged we started about 72 000 and
then and in the last year about 110 to
115 000. good for you what do you guys
do for a living
so i own my own education consulting
company working with charter schools and
my wife is our customer service
relations person all right very cool
good for you guys so what kind of debt
was the 175
000
uh 120 of it was student loans
um there was three cars credit cards and
some orthodontist work
wow
that's a lot of student loan debt
yeah
that's not mine
it's the educational consulting guy yeah
yes exactly
exactly i love it very cool okay how
long you guys have been married
so it'll be 19 years on june 20th
actually so after 13 or 14 years you
looked up and said this sucks
something's got to change tell me your
story what blew you up what made you
change
we uh tom had purchased the financial
piece
he had read it and then
told me about it
we had a second child i was home with
him and our daughter daughter
and we just built a budget
and the student loans just weren't going
away yeah i think that was a big part of
it there was this
yeah they just weren't uh going away
they're just looking at you
yeah
sallie mae has her own bedroom in the
house okay
yes yeah it was more than our mortgage
and it just wasn't going down at all and
we just we just got sick and tired of
being sick and tired and said hey let's
let's just try this plan and you know
jennifer did a great job with the cash
envelopes and really you know held us to
the plan and the process and then um
actually when covid came is actually
when we really started to get momentum
and
and um and and you know use some of the
opportunities that i had as a business
owner to actually help really pay down
debt at a higher rate
wow okay
wow good for you guys okay so jennifer
you're at home with the baby you get out
the book that he bought a while back you
read the book financial piece you say
we're getting on a budget that's kind of
starts the momentum heading the right
way and then you kicked it into high
gear during covet am i getting this
right
that's that's about right yes okay yeah
we um we saw things we started to see
some results after we were able to
actually pay for a car
and thought you know this is going to
work and we can we can do this
so paying off the little one first gave
you a little hope
yes exactly yeah and that increases your
intensity always yeah
way to go guys paying for cash for
things yeah i'm curious when we hear
folks tell us that there's a period in
their debt free journey where they
really start to make up serious ground
obviously tom you you mentioned uh the
coveted season and some specifics but
i'm just curious in that budget
sacrificing that gazelle intensity what
did it look like for you all what'd you
do what was tough about it what came out
of it
yeah good you go jen
well
staying staying on budget
hello
oh i believe we lost them i believe we
did all right we'll put you on hold see
if we can get you guys back up we don't
want you we don't want to lose you on
your debt free scream for sure
well open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five let me try
that i'll pull that line back up to see
if it's there uh tom and jennifer do you
happen to be there
hey guys tom and jennifer oh you're back
good okay all right we've had some we
had some kind of electronic blip we've
got uh lightning strikes happening all
around us here in tennessee okay so
oh way to go guys so we thought we lost
you but you're back
um so the uh what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is
you gotta you gotta trust the process
and i think that's really the hardest
part dave is just really staying focused
we made a budget you gotta stick to the
plan
and uh you know
you know sometimes the hard part was was
when he had a debit card like nope i
don't have the cash on me we're not
going to use it and just really really
seeing you know the end i think one
thing was that i never thought myself as
being debt-free of the student loans it
just wasn't even like a visual but once
we actually saw the end in line and saw
the money that we had you know coming in
and could use them and how much the
growth with the business had during
covet like it got it got really intense
fast and we solved the end so it you
know that's that's just the key is
seeing the vision so your business did a
lot better during covet
oh yeah we had our best our best years
under cove this you know evolution of
the um of our own actual plan in the
business and the profit increased and we
use the profit i was just with 3 000
business owners last week in orlando and
among them i think people are just now
able to say i have my best year ever
during covid because it felt like
because other people were hurting it
felt like it was uh inappropriate to say
i'm winning you know
and they're like it's it's just now far
enough the other side of cover that it's
okay to say it without feel like you're
shaming somebody else or something
absolutely i mean it wouldn't have been
great to be in the plexiglass business
during covet i mean oh my gosh you know
you know i mean
no shame on the plexiglas guy he just
happened to be in the right place at the
right time he made bank everybody
everybody wanted his stuff you know and
you were same for same with you i'm
happy for you i'm glad you were able to
succeed during that time you didn't hurt
anybody you helped people that's you
know but it was kind of a thing where we
we weren't allowed to say we're
succeeding during covet it's like it was
culturally inappropriate so hey we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
we're very
proud of you guys we think that's the
next chapter in your story
also a copy of the total money makeover
and a one-year subscription to financial
peace university in every dollar uh all
as our gift to just say congratulations
if you've done all of that or any of
that you want to give it away pay it
forward feel free to do that or do it
all yourself we we just love you we're
proud of you we think you're incredible
congratulations how does it feel to be
debt-free
free
amazing yes as our son said stress-free
yeah absolutely good for you guys well
congratulations we're proud of you very
very well done all right it's tom and
jennifer in north carolina
175 000 paid off in five years
most of that student loans
making 72 to 110
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
[Music]
i think the young man got excited i
think we got a little harmony going yeah
a little harmony there
good little mix that's excellent very
very well done you guys
that's perfect
good job dude the young man off the top
ropes
comes out of the corner there's an
atomic slam right there that's excellent
very well done
[Laughter]
well he probably got his mom and dad
back now you know we're debt-free you
know they've been working their butts
off thinking about nothing else yeah i
thought it was amazing that when you
asked them how does it feel
both they uh weighed in but then they
said they used the words of their son
who got enough of the journey to
appreciate it to say amazing it's pretty
feels amazing he's a teenager and he's
excited it's hard to get teenagers
excited about anything except for cell
phones food yeah
that's awesome yeah hey man that's
pretty incredible that really that's a
great story i'm so proud of y'all it's
good stuff so a lot of student loan debt
paid off today and the debt free screams
that we've done on the air here and um
you know well biden just paid off five
billion dollars worth of stew just
forgave five billion dollars worth of
student loans did you see that headline
last week no i missed him well he did it
was all over the news um
but only biden didn't forgive five
billion dollars with student loans
there's five billion dollars worth of
student loans to a private college
called corinth college that went broke
and when a private college goes broke
the people who got the student loans and
got ripped off by that college
all those loans are automatically
forgiven that plan has been in place for
25 years yeah so he's not a biden plan
biden didn't have anything to do with it
there's a natural occurrence of the
existing regulations
has nothing to do with student loan
forgiveness it's a standard regulation
god these politicians
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today first peter 4 8
above all love each other deeply because
love covers over a multitude of sins
oliver wendell holmes says sin has many
tools but a lie is the handle
which fits them all
i've never seen that i haven't either
i'm a big fan of this
great
quote sin has many tools but a lie
is the handle which fits them all yeah
brilliant brilliant metaphor there i
gotta chill that's just
there's so much going on in that little
quote that's uh that's um
the oliver wendell holmes that's how you
do that right there if you're him wow
amazing rebecca is in detroit hey
rebecca welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi ken how are you guys great
how can we help
god i just wanted to give you guys both
a shout out i've been such a big fan
dave growing up listening to you driving
home with my dad in the car um like from
a young age i've just been
so impacted by your ministry and then
penn later on out of my college years i
found you and i've just been like a huge
huge fan so thank you both for all you
guys thank you have done and thanks for
taking my call sure thank you how can we
help
yeah so um i'll give you a little bit of
uh stats here and then i'll kind of get
asked my question but
um so
i have been married for two years uh my
husband and i take home about 155 000 a
year um last month we paid off the last
student loan to hunt so we are
free
how old are you yeah
um so i am 28 my husband is 29. good way
to go yeah thank you so much
currently we have about 60 000 in liquid
cash 100 000 in our 401k
and we net about four to five thousand
that we can put in savings
um so my my question to you guys is um
my my husband's mom unfortunately um
passed yes uh last year
and we're going to be inheriting about a
third of her pete or home so it's
looking to be about 80 to 90 000
that we would be inheriting and
we're in the process of figuring out if
we want to just pay cash
um outright and save our first home or
if we you know would take on a mortgage
and um you know finance a portion of it
as time goes on but we're comfortable
right now we live in a like a two
bedroom two bath um but we're just we're
just trying to make the most wise
decision
we are renting right now okay and so
you've got 60 000 cash some of that's
your emergency fund how much do you
think that that is your emergency fund
that's about 20 000 dave okay so 40 is
available cash plus the 90 you're going
to get from the house right
that's correct so 130 000
correct and then the the one thing i
just want to add and i i'd love to your
insight too is i'm actually thinking
about doing a career change down the
road here was starting my own spa
business for massages and facials
um so we're just trying to figure out if
it makes more sense for us to just like
wait
um you know and save uh so that we can
just pay cash for a first home or you
know
our income might change down the road so
we're just trying to make the best
decision
i assume your income is going up down
the road
yeah yeah would you make a career change
where your income went down
uh i was just we're just considering
down the road if if we come to the
decision we want to have children if if
i were to stay home and focus on growing
you know our business my business
um you know it's just down the road if
we if our income changes by one of us
staying home
that's not a career change that's just
deciding to go home
okay the career changes you move into
massage therapy
yeah yeah so
i would i would actually you're
wandering all over the place you need to
decide what you're going to do and then
that'll help you decide what you're
going to do if you want to own your own
massage therapy
business or whatever you can get that to
a point build that up to a point to
where you can go home and
run the business be the founder ceo
and have people replace you it gives you
a lot of options but you don't need to
be too worried about that
as it relates to this question about
that
that's that's kind of definitely the
only question is this do you want to buy
a house with 130 000 down
now or do you want to wait and save up
the entire amount
that's the only question
all the career crap you decide later
yeah for sure no thanks for that i would
say we're just so like focused on being
debt-free obviously okay so we're just
we're just we're thinking that you know
we want to just wait um and and save
um and white inside purchase
yeah so what what what is the target
what are we saving how much how much is
the down how much is the purchase price
of the house
that you're gonna pay cash for
yeah i mean it probably would be between
220 250 so we would wanna so you got 130
so you need another hundred thousand
right so how fast we're gonna have
another hundred thousand making 155 with
no payments
pretty fast two years old
yeah do it two years yeah you're gonna
be 30 and you're gonna pay cash for a
225 230 000 house you got two years yeah
budget it do it lay it out as a goal
break it down attack it i love it and
you're comfortable it's not like your
life is uncomfortable you're comfortable
absolutely do it you're going to need it
for a quarter million dollar house when
you turn 30 years old
and your mom helped you with a little
bit of that or his mom helped with a
little bit of that and that's honoring
to her
it's honoring to her memory it's very
cool yes do all of that
and then
decide what you're going to do with a
massage therapy or staying home with a
kid that's not even here yet
so yeah you can't
okay we don't plan
when you plan a career change
you plan it to make more money or make
as much money unless you're just simply
going to quit
and go home right right that's right and
you and even then you plan can we live
on his income then that's right and and
i have our dreams come true so what's
happening here is dave as we hear this a
lot is that people are following the the
baby steps which is the best plan
for financial wealth and and and what
happens though is you start to go wait a
second uh
do i keep following the financial plan
but what about my professional decision
no the financial plan works in lockstep
with any decision that you would make
but you stay on the financial plan so in
this case you focus completely on what
is the best financial decision that we
want to make if they want to buy a house
cash then do that and that doesn't have
any
that doesn't change what you might want
to do down the line you you make your
career and professional decisions within
the context of financial peace and by
the way it always works
our financial goals that's right so you
make x today with your current career
and you need to start doing this massage
therapy and building the business on the
side hustle correct that will add money
to your house fund
while you're building this other
business up and then when it gets big
enough that the step is not a very big
step you take the step that's right to
doing it full time and or you adjust the
way you do the business so you can stay
home and manage the business from home
with the new kiddo which is what you
said earlier that was a brilliant
insight well it's what we do with entre
leadership entre leadership is is why we
you know we help people go from
entrepreneur and then they begin to have
to hire and so they got to now grow the
business and that's what we do over
there so if you're going to start
something i want you to start something
and keep it and take that season to be a
stay-at-home mom oh but oh by the way
you're a founder and a ceo and you've
got a great team in place and so that
you have the option that when the kid
goes to middle school or whatever that
looks like you have the option to
continue to go back into that role and
keep that business as a vibrant uh
organism that continues to spin off
wealth because we're debt-free in every
other area of our life that's what we
want you to do ideally don't give up the
business necessarily
unless you're going you know what it's
not a passion play so here's the play
though here's what i want folks to hear
out of the essence of
underlying
on this call
there's two things that are mythology
if i do what i love right i make less
correct
if i do
good work
that's a spiritual calling i make less
both of those are mythology
if i transition to being self-employed
i make less
also mythology
assuming you choose to do those steps
properly following the ken coleman
method and then you're going to be there
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books thanks to austin ben zack
andrew and james in the booth i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you